on a quiet country road in berkshire
police are responding to reports and
armed gang
have stolen a quad bike and are towing
it away
as they come face to face with the
suspect's vehicle
one of the two officers inside the
patrol car
is pc andrew harper answering a routine
call
unaware of the tragedy that lies ahead
as one of the suspects makes a run for
it and their car tries to push past the
police vehicle
pc harper can be seen briefly on the
rear-facing camera
running towards the car a split second
later
it takes off dragging the young officer
behind it
his colleague desperately tries to catch
up relaying information
back to the control room before my
colleague pc harper got out the vehicle
i ran after the vehicle i've now lost
him
caught in a tow rope the car had used to
pull the quad bike
pc harper was dragged along the road at
high speed for a mile
suffering catastrophic and fatal
injuries
his personal equipment was left
scattered along the road
then further on his colleagues his
friends
were faced with the most harrowing scene
there's a body in the road bobby in the
road just fell out the vehicle kentucky
go with the body
before that's probably pc harper i just
found it stabbed
in the road now the three occupants of
that car
19 year old driver henry long and his
two
18 year old passengers albert bowers and
jesse cole
have been convicted of killing pc harper
when the police stands and these three
came together
in uh in admiral lane they've made
they've made a decision
and their decision was as the jury have
heard is that they'll get away from the
police at all costs
and each one of them has said that that
they would they would make sure that
they wanted to get away from the police
at all costs
and that cost has caused andrew to lose
his life within minutes of pc harper's
death
last august a police helicopter spotted
the suspect
silver seat parked up in a nearby
traveler's site
yeah i think the seats on the side of
four houses i've got a seat i think
very very hot a number of males around
it this time
police body worn camera recorded the
moment officers arrested henry long
and albert bowers on far more serious
charges
than the theft of a quad bike i'm
arresting both of you
on suspicion of murder
all right and that's of a thames valley
police officer so it's suspicious
of a thames family police officer does
it look like i've done a murder
guy
calling me a murderer all right so do
you two both understand
the suspects had been caught on cctv in
the hours before the robbery
driving around the local area looking
for items to steal
before settling on the quad bike later
that night
as the bike's owner spotted them he
dialed nine nine nine
ten sally please watch emergency i've
got four masked men outside my house and
they've got weapons
oh and they're stealing my squad bike
i'm going out there now no no don't go
out there i'm going out there no because
throughout this has been a highly
complex case
the jury taken on a site visit to the
spot where pc harper
was dragged to his death a computer
reconstruction
helping explain the precise sequence of
events
it has been a very difficult case
because when uh the crown prosecution
service and thames valley police
joined forces we had 10 in custody and
obviously they'd all been arrested from
the caravan site with no one saying
anything there was no
forensic evidence or in fact direct
evidence to link
anyone with the vehicle and so it was
analysis of
phones particularly that linked henry
long
and albert bowers to the offense
by all accounts andrew harper was an
extremely popular
and dedicated officer he'd been married
just
four weeks before the tragic events that
ended his life
he and his colleague were at the end of
their shift but still decided to respond
to the robbery
his senseless death an illustration of
the highly unpredictable nature of the
job
no officer expects to die on duty but
they know the risks are ever present